we want to play a video a recent video
it's with another gentleman who does
transmedia or talks about transmedia and
his name is Huston Howard and he's an
author and an instructor here at La film
school and this video as of many videos
with Huston has done incredibly well so
I want to play it it's got a lot of
comments here so all that to get back to
saying if you're the the small
independent producer that has a low
budget you have to figure out a way to
compete you have to figure out a way to
survive to thrive to exist in this
market and it's tough to out punch
everybody
you can't overpower Star Wars you can't
overpower fortnight or any of these
other things now you have to be craftier
right so you can't just inundate the
world with marketing with with posters
with trailers you can't buy TV spots so
what can you do and so if you have a
good idea if you have a good story and
you're a great storyteller now there's
all these really interesting tools that
we can use to now send your story out
and capture the attention the audience
right and so it's not necessarily about
putting one fishing lure out there now
I'm now that we have so many tools we
can have 10 or 12 fishing lures out
there simultaneously fishing in 12
different ponds all all the time looking
for audience and and so what I get
though is independent creators saying
one I don't know how to do it or even if
they know how to do it they say that
seems like a lot of work right and that
like that to me that is is such the
wrong mindset to have right because we
talked about this in the first round of
interviews we did is I always encourage
independent filmmakers to be thinking as
entrepreneurs rather than just an artist
and because when you're when you're
creating IP when you're creating when
you're launching a film you're launching
a small business you're setting up an
LLC you're staffing it with a crew and
you're creating something and you have
to think of yourself just like the guy
is open in the coffee shop or the woman
that's opening the pizza shop or the
family that's opening of the candle
store down the street you have to have
that same mentality and so though like
if you understand the amount of hours
and hard work it is to launch your own
business then you you they independent
filmmakers understand it in context of a
film they're fine with spending 18 hours
a day on a film set for you know twelve
straight days they that's fine because
that's they think that's just within the
context of what they do but now it's
broadened to where now you have to learn
how to you have to learn how to broaden
the scope of that to have a have a more
more skill sets at your disposal in
order to compete in this crazy market so
as a pizza shop owner can't say well I
love to make pizza that's my thing I'm
not gonna worry about the bookkeeping
because you know who cares about that
well I'm not gonna worry about you know
the front of the house I'm not gonna
worry about these other things all I'm
gonna do is make my pizza
the business owner the chef may but the
business owner has to concern themselves
with everything they have to know the
full scope of everything and they have
to be able to put in the hours and the
work to be able to figure that stuff out
if they want a successful business and
even even when they do that most small
businesses fail and they fail primarily
either because of lack of quality or
they don't figure those other things out
right they though they can't figure out
how to compete and so so it's such an
audacious thing to say you want to be a
filmmaker for the rest of your life this
is your dream and what you want to do is
you want to live your life
professionally making movies for the
rest of your life that is such a first
world crazy dream to have which is an
awesome dream and that that if it's in
your heart
100% go for it but you have to
understand how rare that is and how
audacious that is and the big disconnect
within especially independent filmmakers
is they have this audacious dream of how
they want to live the rest of their life
just making the movie like their own
movies and that's their job forever they
have this idea
just dream but at the same time don't
want to go the same audacious route to
be able to put in the work to learn all
the stuff you need to do to compete to
do to make that happen right and what
they say to me is they say well
Tarantino didn't do that
I mean Tarantino brookie and like you
know Beyonce doesn't do this or like a
point to they point to these people that
one broke in in a different era first of
all like we talked about how fast things
change now like things have changed from
2019 like 2015 to 2019 completely
different let alone when Tarantino
broken into the mid-90s right like you
it's not the same world it's not the
same thing and and the problem that I
think people have is they look at
Tarantino or they look at Scorsese they
look at these people score say she
doesn't do transmedia
I don't need to do transmedia right Wow
okay so I think he read my blog post
about independent filmmaking as a
start-up I literally paralleled how
startup companies how filmmaking is a
lot like startup culture where you've
got a bootstrap and everything else I
disagree with the idea of Beyonce cuz
Beyonce busted her but since she was a
kid working hard at what she was doing
Tarantino had somebody that believed in
him and funded him and also because
you're so eccentric and those
eccentricities to attract people and the
whole idea of transmedia is I don't not
doing transmedia because of to try and
drop other lures into the pond to fish I
do it because it's innate to my
storytelling I create transmedia
projects which I call student
experiences because I want to build out
story world's I want to tell different
point of view a different part of the
story in a different way I do it's
interesting he has a lot of different
things that I talk about all the time
like I think film schools
students and film schools need to take a
programming class si s classes and they
also need to take a class in marketing a
class in accounting and a class in law
those are all things that I do a lot of
almost on a daily basis and I think that
film schools are improperly educating
their students for what it's really like
out there it's interesting because he
also talks about about building out
audiences and doing different things but
I firmly believe that it's actually
audience building early on and you take
that audience through a series of events
not necessarily like trying to pick out
different elements and hoping you're
gonna find audience I want to take
audiences along for a ride I don't
necessarily want them just to be
entertained by this little thing and
this little thing over there it's just I
just have a different business model
yeah I do agree with a lot of things
that he's saying especially from the
business standpoint but in terms of I'm
not certain that I got anything about
like transmedia producing though quite
honestly okay well he has other videos
we could something why why coding and
why law though those I get the marketing
part but all I do al all the times you
deal with contracts are this contractual
people don't realize you need to clean
China title for a film and people don't
probably don't understand what kind I'm
saying right now and that's why I need
to know law is because if you're selling
a property you need to literally make
sure that that that that you have a
clear chain of title when you'll have a
film property it's an IP just like you
have a piece of real estate right that's
property property right and so you need
to basically make sure your ever
copyrights in place you have to make
sure that you know you you did a title
check yet to make sure all these sorts
of things so you can then if you if you
end up selling your film to a
distributor you have a clean chain of
title but law like you know like your
contracts you music contracts your actor
you know deal memos like there's so much
law I deal with it's it's insane I mean
I do have attorneys not to say that I'm
only good Turney let's say that at all
but then with coding because we become
such a
the film and Technology are merging so
quickly that I think there's a lot of
opportunity lost in people to understand
what coding is and how it does like I
can't code myself when I was younger I
knew more coding I do want to share the
concepts I understand UX and all these
sorts of things that I can literally
articulately articulate what I want a
coder to do and what I want to achieve
and I know enough about it to get myself
in trouble but like CES is so important
now because you have stories they can be
told through apps you know it's another
device you can use as a storytelling
tool and that's kind of why I say you
know CS I think when he was talking
about Tarantino and Beyonce I guess he
was trying to say and maybe it's the
point of where we started the video that
most filmmakers already think some some
filmmakers think right out of the gate
that they are at that level that's the
arrogance okay he was trying to say that
people aren't that yet if we've played
it further yeah so that's so just just
as a caveat or whatever but so I think
that that going back right everyone
thinks that well my esoteric idea is is
it's just totally different and they're
gonna come to me I don't need to go to
that kind of thing so no I it's funny
because I I I agree with them of that
it's a matter of you you have to look at
this as a business you each one of your
each one of your films is a new business
like and the one thing is it's like I
don't necessarily sell my films I
license them but I don't sell them so I
still own all the rights to all my
projects you've never sold why so we
sold ones only film we didn't make money
on so you sold it to a distributor did
you do sort of due diligence did you
research the distributor make sure the
other producers went against what I
wanted I straight up and and so forth
and and and it just is what it is it's I
don't know how else to explain it you
know just a business decision that they
made they had more more you know what's
going on again that I did but but yeah
it's just one of those things so like I
look at as long game just like how these
different sorts of distributor
own all this content and that's what
gives them wealth or value it's the same
sort of thing with my dream machine it's
like we all want a bunch of content that
eventually I could sell off of I wanted
to you know but I retain all the rights
to all my stuff you learned from that
initial experience even though you
didn't have them the stake and a
decision that no more distribution deals
you license it but you're gonna
ultimately own it is that the final sort
of verdict yeah yeah yeah well yeah it's
it's um I'm I explained it I've never
been short-sighted I guess I've always
looked at it as a long view have I
wished that like I've made millions of
dollars on my projects absolutely but at
the same time I still have a career and
I've been doing this for 20 years you
know so there's something that I'm doing
right but I got to tell you it's all
because of the business acumen that I
have it's also my creative - am i I
shouldn't just kind of create it because
I do just do some crazy stuff and you
know I'm you know not so boring I think
you know as well but it's interesting
because I the the reason that I got
really deep you're into transmedia was
because I realized that the audiences
were fragmenting meaning that for me to
reach an audience
I couldn't just tell have a feature film
that went into theatres I had to create
stories that people could also be on the
mobile devices I wanted to create a way
that people could use the different
screens and I wanted to tell a different
part of the story on each of those
screens you know when I was releasing in
search of the entire industry fell apart
you know all the distributors weren't
the hell you know the stock market
crashed everything else and and so like
I had to kind of pick up the pieces and
it was very expensive film to make and
sir job was and and so I had to figure
out how I was gonna make money that's
why I was an early adopter to all these
all these digital platforms and so forth
but you know so I came to transmedia one
is I've been doing it I think all my
life and the term never was coined a
hundred Jenkins at MIT was a person that
coined the term transmedia and and but
I'm just as I said I'm getting away from
that term
inexperience because I also do live
events and everything else around it as
well which also generates more capital
you know so for instance what we're
doing is with the WTO 8960 the radio
station that we created for the con for
them for the project is we then hold
live events with the bands you know so
we obviously charge admission we pay
that bands you know we have a great time
so but that's yet another revenue stream
that we've created what do you think
people get wrong about transmedia what
do most filmmakers fail oh well I got to
tell you I debate some very big people
in the transmedia space and they are
arms of marketing they're generally
brought in after the fact after the
property's been made to actually help
market the film where the way that I do
it it's built into the story DNA early
on and it's interesting because I've had
at agencies that have come to me to
create transmedia
elements around a given property and I
do it pretty quickly just because again
my family background I can't I can't I
can't escape that because I just was
raised a different way that this is
built into my vision this is built into
like how I create you know what all my
films I've done this and and and it's
just really weird that that that and I
know what works and doesn't work the
biggest thing is like you can't create a
lot of friction for the audience a lot
of transmedia
producers they want to do this and we're
gonna do that know wouldn't this be cool
all we should do that the problem is is
the more friction that you create for
your audience the less audience you're
gonna have you know so you have to kind
of be open and also lessen the
suspension of belief the more real you
can make something the easier it is for
your audience to actually believe in it
and want to participate in in in all the
content for instance if you do a legacy
fi the project transmedia project you
have to suspend belief before you even
start to play with the elements of the
creation right cuz it's sci-fi it's not
real right and so so you have to suspend
belief but then all of a sudden you put
these hurdles in place that you people
have to go to X Y & Z and then do this
and do that to be able to you know get
the content
you're asking a lot of your audience and
I know for a fact because we've done
this I've we have case studies behind it
in things that you have to create the
least amount of friction possible for an
audience for them to buy into it like
people when they go to our shows don't
realize they're stepping into my into my
film world it's kind of cool but do they
still don't you know get it until
they're there for a bit so sorry let me
see if I understand friction so friction
would be where there's like sort of too
many things going on in terms of
diverting attention so that you could
create another story not necessarily
just that but could be just something
that you have in your website that you
want somebody to view something and then
they have to answer for questions to be
able to unlock a mystery code to be able
to do - then you access a QR code that
then brings you to a mobile app that
brings you back to a microsite it's like
you don't and I'm saying like all these
crazy things for people to do yeah it's
fun it's a puzzle you know we can do
some stuff with a are do the same sort
of idea but I think you have to simplify
it for the audience because this is new
for people that's a big thing and so the
thing is it's like it's like but people
have to be willing to you have to make
content so compelling that they want to
see the other parts of it though - you
had to be successful so like with
billboard people are see in the film
then they are downloading the webseries
you again listen to my audience is like
we originally had 28 episodes of the web
series that range anywhere from 90
seconds to seven minutes realized that
the UX was cumbersome for the viewers UX
meaning user interface was too
cumbersome for the viewers that I had to
listen to them and I and I collapsed
them down and made nine longer ones you
know again it's not it's me not being
arrogant because of I had to listen to
my audience I'm confident in my content
and not afraid to do that because I can
do it but at the same time as a matter
of like I realize that I've created
friction for my audience to be able to
enjoy that content that we've created
you